GREG KUELGEN: Hi.
My name's Greg Kuelgen,
and I'm an architect
with Apigee at Google Cloud.
DINO CHIESA: Hi,
I'm Dino Chiesa.
I'm a colleague of Greg's on
the Apigee team at Google Cloud.
GREG KUELGEN: So I'm
very excited to be
here today to talk to you
about some means of securing
your APIs.
There are a couple of key
points we hope you take away
from this session.
One-- API security is
not one size fits all.
Depending on the purpose of the
API, the audience, the data,
et cetera, there'll be
varying techniques you
may use to protect that API.
While there are
certainly some things
we'd use base requirements--
for example, transport layer
security-- the
approaches we talk
about are designed to be layered
and used where appropriate.
Two-- security is not static.
What works today may
need to adapt tomorrow.
Three-- tools like
Apigee can help manage
the security of your APIs.
Dino and I frequently talk to
customers about API security.
Over the past few years, the
number of attacks that we see
and the number of conversations
we have about security
have been steadily increasing.
Securing access--
this is generally
what I believe most
of us think about when
we think API
security, making sure
that we have authentication
and authorization in place.
As the slide states, the
caller presents something,
and the receiver checks to see
if access should be granted.
In basically all
cases, you want to use
TLS to secure the connection,
also known as one-way TLS.
So let's talk about a few
means of actually securing
your access.
First, API key.
I really think of
an API key more
as a way to identify a calling
app than a true security
mechanism, though it's often
a building block for security
mechanisms, such as OAuth.
OAuth is a very commonly
used method of authentication
and authorization.
It has allowances to let
a consumer authenticate
their account and approve
access for certain parts
of their account.
We've all gone through this
authorization flow, where
you log into an
account with an app,
it redirects you to another
log-in, such as your Google
log-in, and asks whether you
grant the app permissions
to access your data.
In one-way TLS, which is
another means of securing,
the client identifies the
server with the certificate
presented by that server.
With a two-way TLS connection,
the server similarly
identifies the client.
TLS certificates for clients
can be difficult to manage.
They generally aren't used
with open API programs,
though they are certainly
used for some partners that
may access privileged
APIs, often
in conjunction with other
authentication mechanisms.
For example, third
party payment processors
may be using a bank's
actual payment APIs--
often have to have their servers
present client certificates
as part of their access.
Like I already
mentioned, API key
is really used for
its simplicity.
We highly recommend OAuth.
There are different
grant types that
can be utilized based
on the level of trust
and other requirements.
A simple client
credentials grant type,
where a system passes a
client ID and a secret,
might work well for a
trusted internal system.
A third party app that allows
access to individual data,
on other hand, would need to
use an authorization code flow,
like I previously described,
where the consumer authorizes
the access.
Finally, I'll mention that
TLS certs used for two-way TLS
make a lot of sense when you're
using a service mesh that
can manage all of that for you.
One of the things in common
with all of these methods
is that they identify
the calling client.
OAuth tokens, however, can also
identify not just the client,
but the end user as well.
So Dino, what
situations do you see
customers using these
different mechanisms
to secure their API access?
DINO CHIESA: Well, the API key
is a good basic building block.
It's appropriate for use with
an open API, where you want
to track who's calling the API.
And also, it can be
used as a key identifier
when doing signing
or encryption.
I'll talk more about that later.
OAuth is pretty
common, as you said.
Most API gateways
will just support it.
It's a really good idea.
Two-way TLS, that's going
to work for devices that are
managed--
point of sale terminals,
devices that you control.
Not so easy for consumer
mobile devices or even partner
systems.
GREG KUELGEN: Great.
What about JSON web
tokens, or "jots"?
Can I use those for
authorization access?
DINO CHIESA: Sure you can.
JWT is just a special
kind of token.
OAuth bearer tokens are commonly
opaque, a random string.
No information is inherent
within that string.
A JWT is different.
It encodes actual claims.
With an opaque token, only
the authorization server
that issued the token
can resolve that token
into a set of claims
or entitlements.
In contrast, any system
can decode and verify
the information in a signed JWT.
So yes, JWT can be
used as a bearer token
to support authorization
checks, and it
may be more flexible and
preferred in some cases.
When to use each?
As always, it depends.
That's a larger conversation.
GREG KUELGEN: Spoken like a
true architect-- it depends.
I've used that phrase
many times myself.
Now let's talk about securing
your API messages themselves.
I've worked with a customer
that was dealing with consumer
credit information.
As you might imagine,
they're passing
around personally
identifiable information
that we would all
prefer not be leaked.
They use things like TLS
and OAuth, of course,
but in addition,
they actually chose
to pass some incoming payloads
as a JWT using JSON web
encryption.
For those transactions,
it gave them
an extra layer of security.
Even if someone got
a valid OAuth token,
they still needed to sign and
encrypt the message itself.
At a high level,
there are really
two key items when it
comes to message security--
signatures and encryption.
Signatures provide message
integrity and non-repudiation.
Basically, a signature can
contain a hash of the message
and is often signed
using a secret
only the signer
possesses, but can
be verified by the receiver.
In this way, we can verify that
the message hasn't been altered
and has actually been sent
by the intended sender.
Signatures don't provide
any privacy for the message,
though.
For that, you need encryption.
A combination of
signatures and encryption
can be used to protect
sensitive data.
HMAC is also used pretty
widely by cloud providers.
For example, in
GCP, you can create
a side URL that allows
distributed access to a storage
bucket.
Using encryption
can be useful if you
want to protect against things
like a TLS vulnerability
that would allow an attacker
to view data in flight.
It can also be
useful to limit who
is able to see data as
it moves between systems
or when stored on
disk along the way.
Generally speaking,
this is only going
to be used for your
most sensitive data.
This leads me to
another question.
Dino, do you have any
recommendations for when
folks should use these different
message security mechanisms?
DINO CHIESA: Sure.
Here are a few.
First, keep it simple.
Signing or encryption
necessarily means more work
for client developers
and more complexity.
Take care to apply
it thoughtfully.
Second, application layer
signing or encryption
helps protecting information
across multiple hops
in a chain.
Third, select the signing
approach that fits your team.
So HMAC, RSA-- whichever
they're most comfortable with.
And don't forget, JWT can
be used to sign or encrypt
payloads, not just ID tokens.
In all these cases,
you're going to need
to think about key management.
Last, include a timestamp
in the signed payload
to protect against replays.
JWT will help you with this.
If you use HMAC or RSA,
you will have to come up
with your own convention.
GREG KUELGEN: Great.
Thanks, Dino.
Securing conversations-- even
with other security measures
in place, sometimes
attackers create
accounts to try to mimic
human users and gain access.
Rarely, though, do these
attacks follow the same patterns
as normal use.
Securing conversations generally
makes use of modern technology
like machine learning to
consider usage patterns
and potentially identify
malicious traffic.
This is where we start to
get into things like bots.
There are plenty of
bots with bad intent.
It can take advanced features
to help identify and prevent
this type of attack.
There are a few
things in the toolkit
for securing conversations.
One of the simplest
can be rate limiting.
It's unlikely, for
example, that a human
will be requesting a new
token several times a second,
or even more than once a minute.
Anomaly detection has also
seen an uptick with customers
that I support.
As we talked about, sometimes
bad actors get through
and that can change the error
rate, or the overall rate
of traffic, even.
Anomaly detection applies
machine learning models
to understand what
a normal traffic
flow looks like, and can alert
when things like the error rate
are outside of normal.
This is all done without
anyone actually configuring
a specific alert.
Security teams have come
to rely on these alerts
as a potential indicator
that a bad actor is bypassing
other security mechanisms.
It also works great to alert to
potential operational issues,
and I've had more
than one customer that
has told me anomaly detection
has helped them detect
an error, alert the
target service that
was having the
issue, and fix it all
before they broke their SLO.
You'll also see
reCAPTCHA up here.
Usually when I
think of reCAPTCHA
I think of having to
click on the annoying
images or maybe type some
difficult-to-read characters.
Hey Dino, how could reCAPTCHA
help with securing APIs?
DINO CHIESA: Good question.
So in the original
version of reCAPTCHA,
a web page presents the familiar
"are you a robot" challenge.
Google released version
3 of reCAPTCHA in 2018.
In that version, it now
relies on device and endpoint
fingerprinting.
There is no UI.
That means both web
pages and APIs can be
protected by the same system.
The client needs to connect
to the reCAPTCHA server
to get a token.
That client uses that token in
its request for an API token.
The API server can then
validate the reCAPTCHA token
before granting service,
and reCAPTCHA will issue
an opinion about that client--
is it a robot or is it not?
Using reCAPTCHA
this way, reCAPTCHA
acts as a gatekeeper or
bouncer for your front door.
It does mean introducing
a new external dependency
into your system,
but you may want
to accept that to get the
additional level of security.
GREG KUELGEN: Perfect.
Thank you.
So when do you use what?
API access token pretty much
is always going to be in place.
There are some exceptions
for truly public info,
but even then, you
may want to provide
some level of access control.
Signatures can be
useful when you
need to verify the
integrity of the payload,
or can even be used
for distributed access,
like the signed URL example.
Encryption is useful
when a message
may be passed around
between multiple systems
in an asynchronous manner, or
for the most sensitive data
that you want to
ensure that even
if the wires are compromised,
the content is still secure.
This can also be used to
ensure that messages are secure
even when written to disk
or if they're inadvertently
written to logs.
There are multiple areas
where anomaly to bot detection
might make sense,
but we recommend
that this is at least used
to protect your log-in
and token API.
Ideally, you want to prevent
the bad actors from ever getting
a token in the first place.
With that, let me
turn it over to Dino,
who will walk us through how
we might be able to implement
some of this inside of Apigee.
DINO CHIESA: Information-driven
companies will have tens
or hundreds of services
that they use to run
their business-- some of them
custom-built, maybe in Java,
Golang, C#, Python,
maybe running in a VM
or in Kubernetes.
Some of these services
might be third party--
SaaS.
There are many different
implementation options.
Apigee can help
manage all of them.
To do that, we rely
on an Apigee proxy
that intercedes between clients
of the service and the service.
This allows us to standardize
on the access, message,
and conversation security.
For this demonstration, I have
a single upstream service.
It's implemented in Node.
It uses Express.
It's JavaScript.
And all those
details don't matter.
The key detail is that
it exposes an HTTP API.
So let me show you what it
looks like to invoke that.
The service is running locally.
I have my dev instance.
And you can see it's an
inventory and product
management service.
I can query it and get
information about products.
You can see Anvil, Birdseed,
a bunch of other products.
This is just the dev instance.
I also have it running
in Google App Engine.
So lets try to invoke it there.
There's a different URL.
I'll send the same request.
And you can see I'm getting
a 401 unauthorized--
the service is locked down.
To enforce the
API management, we
must ensure that the
service is accessible only
through the API gateway.
We can do that with two-way TLS,
firewall configuration with IP
restrictions, or via
some other mechanism.
Apigee then acts as the
enforcement point for clients.
No client can reach the service
except through the Apigee
proxy.
So let me show you a
proxy that stands in front
of this particular service.
So here we see the
target of the proxy,
and this is the ingress
endpoint for the API proxy.
The proxy itself is
just a pass-through.
It receives the request and
then proxies to the upstream.
So let me turn on tracing,
and then we'll flip back
and we'll invoke not
the Google App Engine
endpoint, but the proxy
endpoint in Apigee.
You can see I'm sending
that same request,
and it's actually connecting
to that App Engine
instance, which,
because it's Apigee,
it's allowing it through.
And you can see I've got
a trace statement here.
The request is
received, and then it's
proxied to the upstream target.
So really nice, except
Apigee is merely
acting as a pass-through.
We want the proxy to do more.
So in order to illustrate
that, let's stop the trace.
We'll deploy version 12 of
this proxy, which includes
a verify access token policy.
So now we're going
to start doing
OAuth enforcement in the proxy.
Again, let me turn on
a trace, and then I'm
going to run that same request.
And you should see Apigee
saying, hey, unauthorized.
You did not pass a token.
So not going to let you in.
How can we get a token?
Apigee also acts as
a token dispensary,
and I have another
proxy for that.
This is an Apigee
OAuth proxy that
generates tokens for their
client credentials grant type.
So I'm going to turn
on trace for that,
and now we'll request a token
using client credentials.
So that's a different
API request.
And you can see I'm
sending that into Apigee.
And yep, I've got an
access token coming back.
So that's really good.
In the trace, you can see
Apigee handled that request,
it verified the
client credentials,
and then generated
a token, which
is now good for 30 minutes.
We now have the token.
Let's invoke the service again.
We'll switch back
to the other proxy.
We'll invoke the service again,
passing that valid token.
And now you can see Apigee
is receiving the request.
It includes the valid token,
and I'm getting the product
inventory information.
So that's just what we want.
What if I use an
expired access token?
Something that's out of date?
Also want to check that out.
Want to make sure
that access tokens get
rejected when they are expired.
And sure enough, Apigee
is sending back, hey,
that token is old.
That's expired.
It's doing exactly
what we want it to do.
Let's try an update.
For this part of
the demonstration,
I have a payload.
I want to send a post in.
The payload looks like that,
and I've configured the Apigee
proxy in here to check
the HMAC on that payload
to prevent replays and to ensure
greater message security--
something we talked about
a little bit earlier.
So let's try to send
that in, send in a post
with that update, with
that payload as an update.
And you can see
Apigee is sending,
hey, you need to send an
HMAC for that request, which
is, again, what we want.
Let's try sending in that
request with an invalid HMAC--
the wrong HMAC for this payload.
You can see now
Apigee is saying,
ah, well, you sent in an HMAC,
but it was the wrong HMAC.
That HMAC did not succeed.
And here's the one where
we didn't include an HMAC.
Here's Apigee handling
the request where
we did send an HMAC, but
it was the wrong one.
This is the actual
correct HMAC value
that Apigee is expecting
for this given payload.
This is the value that I sent.
So let's send the correct value.
HMAC equals that value, and
we'll send that same request
again with the correct value.
And now Apigee said,
yep, that's good.
That post, we've validated
it, Apigee has validated it.
The HMAC passed, and then
it proxies to the upstream.
The upstream system did
not have to concern itself
with tokens or HMACs.
Apigee is doing all
that work for you.
So I didn't show it
here, but remember,
you'll want to include
timestamps in your HMACs
to prevent replays.
In the prior
examples, the client
used a client
credentials grant type,
passing in the client ID in
secret in the basic auth header
in order to get a token.
How about using a JWT
as an alternative?
Instead of passing a
client ID in secret,
the token endpoint
in Apigee can require
that the client signs
the request for token
using a key payer provision
just for this client.
And we can use as the
signing mechanism JWT--
that's standard.
So how do we do that?
First, we'll get a JWT.
And I'll use this
web page to generate
a signed JWT using
the private key that
is associated to this client.
Let me grab that JWT.
And we'll set that
as a shell variable.
Now I want to open up
the JWT token dispensary.
I'm going to turn
on tracing there.
And then we're going to send
in a request for a token that
passes that JWT.
So here's a new request for
token, passing in the JWT
that I just set.
Here's the grant type-- it's
a JWT bearer grant type.
And now I've got an opaque
access token in exchange
for that signed assertion
from the client.
And that opaque
token will work just
like a token issued with
client credentials grant
type, so that's going to
work just as expected.
What if we use a JWT
ID token to get--
as an exchange for
a bearer token?
So here, this is
a page that allows
me to sign in using Google
Sign-In, which is just
an OpenID Connect provider.
And what that means is
it will issue an ID token
to an app that allows
a person to sign in.
So now I've got a JWT from
Google that's much bigger.
It's got a lot
more claims in it.
You can see some of the
claims here are decoded--
the email address, the name, a
URL for my picture, and so on.
What if we use that
to try to get a token?
We can do that here with a
new, different API proxy.
So this one, rather than
verifying a self-signed JWT
from a client, it's
going to verify
that this is a token
issued by Google Sign-In.
You can use any OpenID
Connect provider--
oxAuth, Auth0, Azure,
Google Sign-In.
There are lots of other
options, but any of them
will have that same kind of
approach with a JWKS endpoint.
So let me try now obtaining
a token with that JWT.
We use a different endpoint.
And sure enough, I'm getting
now an access token in exchange
for an ID token.
So that's a really nice
capability in Apigee.
And you can see the flow
in Apigee allowing that--
verifying that request and
issuing the token back.
And again, that
token will work just
like any other token
issued by Apigee.
How about something
a little different?
What if we want Apigee
to accept a JWT directly?
So I've got a different API
proxy endpoint for that.
This one accepts a JWT, and
it just verifies that JWT.
Again, this will be an ID
token issued by Google.
So we'll turn on tracing for
that API proxy and invoke that,
and you can see the API
proxy is now accepting
the JWT as an input token.
And it's verifying
that directly.
So no opaque token.
Rather, it's the full ID token
issued by Google Sign-In.
And as I said, you can use
any OpenID Connect provider
to allow that to happen.
Last thing I want
to show is what
about if we want to protect
the token dispensary
endpoint with reCAPTCHA?
And I've got another API
proxy here that does that.
So again, this is a client
credentials token dispensary
in Apigee, but it protects
the request with reCAPTCHA.
And the way this works
will become clearer
after I show you.
The client page looks like this.
So this is a bit of JavaScript
that runs in a browser,
and it uses the reCAPTCHA
SDK from Google.
Here, I use the client
to obtain a token,
a reCAPTCHA token using
the reCAPTCHA site key.
Then after the client
gets the reCAPTCHA token,
it can send in a
request for an API token
to Apigee, passing in
the reCAPTCHA token
as part of that request.
Then Apigee, in the proxy, will
verify that reCAPTCHA token--
it does that here-- before
issuing a client credentials
grant-type token.
So let's see this all work.
I've got the page running
that, and I'll just
click this button.
It's obtaining the
token from reCAPTCHA,
sending that along with a client
credentials grant into Apigee,
and you can see that Apigee
received that request
and verified the token.
Google replied with a
response for that token,
giving it a score of
0.9, which is sufficient.
So the Apigee proxy
issues the token
as it did in all
those other cases.
And that's it.
I hope that gives you a good
idea of some of the things
that you can do with Apigee
for access security, message
security, and
conversation security.
OK, those
demonstrations, I hope,
give you an idea of some
of the possibilities
Apigee offers for
securing your APIs,
focusing on securing access,
securing the messages
themselves, and monitoring and
securing patterns of messages.
So now, I'll turn it back to
Greg to bring it home for us.
GREG KUELGEN: Awesome.
Thanks, Dino.
Great demo.
Today we learned
about different ways
that you can secure access,
most commonly using tokens.
You can secure your API messages
with signatures and encryption,
and finally, how
advanced features,
such as anomaly
detection and reCAPTCHA,
can help secure
your conversations.
You saw these
different techniques
can be applied differently
to different APIs,
briefly see how
you could actually
implement some of these--
this functionality quickly
and easy using Apigee.
I want to truly thank you
for watching this session,
and offer to continue
the conversation.
I've set up some expert
one on one sessions
over the next couple of weeks.
We will also be
answering your questions
in the question and answer
section for this session.
Thank you very much.